a huge overhaul of yorkshire's coaching
staff but also their backroom staff 16
people in total you're right to
highlight moxen and gail they are the
two most high profile moxen the former
director of cricket has been signed off
with stress gail is being had been
suspended pending an investigation into
an allegedly uh anti-semitic tweet azeem
rafika called for both to resign he's
been calling for them to resign for
months now he felt they'd overseen this
racism issue at yorkshire they'd failed
to deal with it he named both of them as
well at the dcms select committee
hearing rafiq saying that gail had used
racial slurs
on more than one occasion in reference
to rafiq and around him he'd never ever
stamped out racial language at the club
he claimed that moxon had discriminated
against him and had shown no sympathy in
2018 when rafiq lost his son so both
were suspended both have now left the
club but as i say this is about far more
than just those two individuals this is
a huge overhaul
and it comes after we learnt of this
institutional racist racism a cultural
issue at yorkshire it comes after the
ecb took international cricket away from
headingley and the sponsors left the
club in their droves now as you say the
new chairman law patel is trying to turn
over a new leaf he's trying to show
both the ecb and the sponsors that this
is a new club that's going to stamp out
racism and he's doing it pretty quickly